入って行きで前のに入ってみる本日は11月1日
ポッキーの日ということで今日はなーんとなーんとですね今日はポッキーを
11110日本食べていると思いますいやー
嘘です爪ねちょっと忙しい別に忙しいわけじゃないして忙しいわけじゃないんですけど
時間がないんですよね
時間がない忙しくはない磯田しかないんですけども時間がないんです
いっ
実はですね昨日東京に行ってまして終電を逃して東京で止まってで今日せ増加に帰って
くるんですけども供述は学校でその学校に行ってきて帰ってきて今にとるんでほんとに
ねちょっとね忙しくないんですけども家にいる時間がないんですよと思えばしたから
また東京がですよ明日あさって東京でいその合間にをちょっと卒論とかを書かなくちゃ
いけなくてですねなかなか
neff 去年みたいにねやいポッキーの日だポッキーたくさん買って食べて言え
ベリー区
余っちゃったみんなであげようみたいなんですねちょっとね人チックなことができない
ですねまぁ悔しいべやすいんですけどなんとンって今を乗り越えてね
来年とになるとねまだ何かこういう色できたらいいなと思ってるんじゃ今まあ我慢の
時期だと思ってるよなので今日はねふんポッキーの日た
ふーんということで質問コーナーの質問リクエストねもうリクエスト他質問を募集し
ます
よかったら高
の動画のコメント欄に僕に対するコメントとか質問とか言いたいこととかをコメントに
帰ってください
今月中には動画を出そうと思っていますよくですねその質問コーナーの質問動画いつ
出すんですかってよく言われるんですけども僕はそういうのねもう感覚でやってるんだ
よなら適当に気が向いたら+います
のメディ待っててくださいそのうち多分な住んで今質問書く時間だけ
はもうみんな人も書いてない
ずっドルって出れきてってってってってるって言うん
俺は最近ふとねー
人生って何だろうって考えるときがあるよあ
もうね難しい爺てってな映像依頼も一番ねそれ時期や大学の卒業だと思ってるんで
それで大学の卒業います頑張ってますね
はい店さんやとりあえずで東京に行ってるとこういう間にへどうぞと時間自体が
無くなってくるんでしょ
なかなかねって常に辛いものがありましたよというでも東京で何かそういう音部屋を
借りようかなと思って言ってそうすればその
こっちでも動画それる主東京でも動画取るっていうちょっと部屋代とか買っちゃうん
ですけどもこんなに東京に行くことがあると本当にね
移動時間というかそういうのでいろいろいっぱいになっちゃって東京でも
酒井んだよね東京たから東京高そうだから嫌なんだよ
いやー
マイティアいやでもね質問コーナーは楽しいよえっちゃ全部のコメント見てるんで時間
がかかったんですけどなかなかセンスのある人がいるんでこちらとしてはありがたいん
で助かってます
いつもみんなありがとうございますそれで卒論で本当にますで俺もお空になったら社会
という穴波にのまれ始めてください
あっはぁっ
ツイッターとかでも集めようとしたんですけどもなんかやっぱ一つで行ったほうが僕も
見やすい
僕も見やすいんでちょっと今回は youtube だけのコメントで母数します
チャンネル登録とコメントをお待ちしておりますねハッ厳しい世の中だよとしばらくは
ねちょっと学生としてねちゃんと俺もね
生活保護ルカを守るからね思うからじゃあ皆さんのコメントお待ちしておりますほっっ
じゃあ
ん